(smack of lips kissing a cheek)
- How are you?
- It's so nice to finally meet you.
- It's so nice to meet you.
Real quick before we get
into this, is he going
to go into the studio and do it again?
What's the plan?
- He just called me, I called
him back, he hasn't picked up
so I'll probably know
in the next 30 minutes.
- Okay.
I'm so glad we're here.
- I am too.
- How are you doing?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Good.
What are you guys in town for?
- I've got a show tomorrow.
- Love it, where?
- La Marina.
- Where is that?
- It's like uptown.
- Like Harlem, Bronx?
- Yeah.
- How you doing, Boyd?
- Doing great.
- I've been giving you so much love.
- No, I seriously--
- No, you know, better than you know.
I did something real crazy for you.
I was with ???? The other
day and they're about
to roll out some fuckin' fresh new shit
and they're like, we
really need somebody who...
And I was like, pull up this account.
I'm doing some real fun stuff.
Obviously the stuff that you guys can see
but behind the scenes stuff I'm up
to for you is really cool.
Hopefully, something will come through.
- Yeah, for sure man, appreciate it.
- That's amazing, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Yeah, like I have like
family members hitting me up
like, "Oh, my God"--
- You know Gary V.?
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- Oh, my God, my grandpa,
my aunt, like my other aunt.
She hit me up today like, oh my gosh,
because I was in Massapequa earlier,
and I posted on my
Instagram and she's like,
"Where are you?", and I was like,
"I'm in New York".
She was like, oh, damn, I thought you was
at Gary V.'s office or something.
I was like, "No, I'm not."
- Thank you.
- But I am gonna meet him later
and she was like, "Oh, my God!"
- I love it.
So what's going on?
What's important, I mean you've done
this with me a couple of times.
How can I help?
I really believe, I love
the empowerment concept...
Like I love what you're doing with like
settling the score with boys in the past.
I really like what you're
doing with the music.
But more importantly,
I genuinely believe...
So Boyd's got his version of an ear.
I must be like in your
head, you've got one ear
and I've got a different ear.
- Yeah, it's terrible.
- And when both of our
ears go, that's when we go.
I really think you're part of a movement
that's gonna be really relevant
over the next 5 to 7 years
and I'd love to help.
I don't know what you guys
think you need help with
or what's been going on.
- I definitely think that just getting
out of Atlanta and expanding.
Really, where I think my strength lies
in is performance.
You know, like my music is great--
- I think you should--
- My music is great.
- You know who's similar? Me.
I'm so good at keynotes,
that's why I do that
and everything feeds off that.
I think you should perform for fuckin'
free everyday, that's how important...
If you told me that you had a film person
like I do, I would tell
you to fuckin' do shit
for free 'cause I think you're so good
that the more of that shit that happens...
Actually, I have a good idea for you guys,
you should do a free
pop-up show that nobody
knows about that's 48 hours in advance.
You just start pushing it out on social.
I'll give it love.
Random, random.
Don't take on any costs.
Find somebody that
needs people to show up.
Or do it ghetto and do it like in
the middle of a park
until they kick you out.
- Yeah.
- Something that just
catches peoples' attention.
I told A-Boogie to do that and he did it
and it fuckin' went, it really worked.
- 'Cause I think a lot of people,
they really love my performances--
- You're so good live.
- Yeah, thank you.
- I mean, I haven't even
seen it but I can see it
through video, you can taste
the energy through the videos.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You love it, right?
- I love performing.
I've been performing
since I was in 3rd grade.
- You were like theater-y
kind of like, right?
- Yeah, I went to performing arts
elementary and high school.
- So what, so how are
you thinking about that?
- So I've talked with
several agents and different
independent promoters looking to
get her to open up on their tours--
- That's the key, right?
- Yeah, 'cause the
Cupcake, when I opened up
for Cupcake, that was crazy.
- Yep, so I tried to
get regionally at first
just because that's--
- What about with all
the female empowerment?
Like what about Pump or
Xan or like that whole
kind of punk rap thing?
She would kill that world.
- Yeah, it's true.
- It's just everybody wants
to open for that, makes sense.
What's Killy doing?
- He's on tour in Europe right now.
- They would be great together.
- Yeah, I also definitely
want to get to Europe.
I have fans that are like,
"Come to London, please, please.
"We need you in London."
- I was in a meeting earlier today
and you came up and--
- What was it, what was it?
- I was at RCA talking to one of
the big shot guys over there and--
- Is that from the email that I knew,
that RCA thread that was going on,
or did you just go
randomly on your own shit?
- I went randomly through Richie.
Richie met one of the big shot guys and--
- Got it.
- He told me to come through.
- But basically--
- Why'd Richie change his
phone number, scandals?
(laughter)
- He changes his number like once a month.
- Why, he's getting into too much shit?
- Well now it's like once
every like three months.
- Girl trouble?
- Probably.
- I don't know man, I don't know.
- That's what it always is.
- You have to block
them, you just got to--
- You know how that goes.
- I know exactly how that goes.
(laughter)
Between fuckin' with you and doing
Baynards Sports, all these guys
are changing their number
every fuckin' week.
(laughter)
I'm getting tired of it,
I'm like, I'm not going
to communicate to anybody no more.
- Oh my God.
But one of the coolest things is that
she produces her own music so that
is actually something that
more people need to know about.
- Yeah, a lot of people don't know that.
- I feel like no one knows that.
- Yeah, and I try to say it but
I don't want to be like...
I don't want to get too
like, "Okay, we get it.
"You produce your own stuff!"
- But your production is so dope.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Like it really is.
If I didn't know you were
producing your own stuff
I would try to find out who
was producing your stuff.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, it's me, it's me.
I've been producing since I was 13 so
a lot of people don't know that.
I don't really know, I was thinking about
doing videos of me making beats--
- You should, you should,
you should, you 100% should.
I've got an idea, why
don't we send somebody
like Seth from 1:37 p.m.?
Even though it's a men's brand,
we want to do some female shit.
I've been wanting to do this thing
called 24 Hours With.
Like what if we just spend,
I mean like in her house.
Let's say Seth was doing it.
Let's say she went home at midnight from
the studio and just slept
from midnight to 7 a.m.
He would literally, it would be weird,
but he'd have to like--
I mean it, that's how I'm doing it.
He would like go to sleep on the couch
and put the camera down and it would
be like a time lapse, one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Like I'm gonna show every hour
of being with a person for 24 hours.
- That would be cool.
- We could do 24 Hours
With Yung Baby Tate.
- We could, 24 Hours With the Baby.
- Who was that, Barack?
I'm gonna steal one of your sushis.
So how can I help from your perspective?
You have a lot of context on me.
- Yeah, so really what we're looking
to do is build out
visually a project, right.
Obviously, it was a goal of ours
to further motivate and inspire us
with Tiara and what she did with
that project was incredible.
- She killed it, she killed it.
- Literally.
- So our goal is to really visually speak
to what Boyd did as a project.
Yeah, you can hear the sound but without
a visual representation it will go over
some peoples' heads, I think.
So we're looking to
really conceptualize and
we'd love to film a video for
every record on the front--
- I just pictured her on something.
We have this site coming
out called 1:37 p.m.
It comes out next week.
Boyd's about to get back into
his Hip Hop At Lunch phase.
We're about to literally he's gonna write
an article about who's next all the time.
- I already hit him up about this.
- So we're launching a
site called 1:37 p.m.
It's like Complex meets Vice meets
Business Insider meets XXL.
It's really like my Huffington Post,
like the shit that I fuck with,
entrepreneurship, music, sports.
It's coming out next week.
There's a series I want to make called
24 Hours With.
One of the things I want to do
is throw a curve ball.
Even though it's for
men, to talk about women
that are hustling and
winning too and grinding.
I think it would be really fresh
if we legitimately, like using Seth,
it probably could be Seth,
he's starting to do some more filming,
but literally film her for 24 hours.
Including when she goes to sleep,
we need to sleep on the couch and put
the camera down and it would just be
like looking at her wall and it would
just say 1 am, 2 am, 3 am,
4 am, 5 am, 6 am, 7 am.
Got it?
It could be really cool.
I think I could get a lot of eyes on it.
- They'll see your mushroom.
(laughter)
- What about music?
What is the next music, what is going on?
- I'm in the process of trying
to decide when I'm going to
go out with the next one because I'm still
in the process of making the next one.
- Are you gonna drop a mixtape?
- Yeah, it's gonna be another EP.
- Have you thought about
dropping a song or two randomly?
- Yeah.
- I really believe in it, man.
- I can't, I know I'm
a broken fuckin' record
but like I just believe in that shit.
I'll give you an example, for
me, outsider paying attention
and really wants you to win, I mean
Tate needs a fuckin' summer anthem.
Like straight up!
What the fuck are you
doing with your summer
with your long ass blonde hair?
(laughter)
You know, like I want to know.
You see were I'm going?
- Yeah.
- But I feel like every
artist that's on the come up,
actually this is my new
fuckin' thing that I just made
up right now, put your
shit out Memorial Day.
You need a fuckin' summer anthem.
Like everybody should--
People haven't caught up to
the way distribution works.
Summer anthems are fucking game changers.
- Yeah.
- Their game changers.
- Very true.
- They're game changers.
- Everybody remembers every summer anthem.
- Absolutely, summer
anthems are game changers!
Put out your fuckin'...
And if you know you're
putting out a summer anthem,
in March you're writing, you're thinking,
you're contemplating and boom,
that's what people should be doing.
- Yeah, I have a lot of stuff on ??
A lot that I could be--
- I get it, listen, I get it.
Like you could just alter it a little,
just change the hook and
it's a summer anthem.
- The thing about her is
that she's not waiting on--
- She produces, do you write?
- Yeah, I write almost--
- She's not waiting to
hear the right record.
- You're a fuckin' one-woman shop.
- Completely.
- Produces, writes, sings, does it.
- There was a time when
I was trying to put
out just any type of content whether
it was video, photo shoots, all that.
- Here's what I would say, three things,
one, we're gonna start
chopping up our idea.
If we want to come out with something on
the Tuesday after Labor
Day is a thing for me.
I like it, but I've got to marinate.
Two, I'd love to do a 24
Hours With you on BBT.
Literally, you've got to get ready though.
You're a cute girl so
if you want me to have
a female videographer...
It's 24 hours, they're
coming to your home.
But I'll send Seth, he's
harmless, he's harmless.
(laughter)
For 1:37 p.m. and that's very
much about entrepreneurship.
I want to know like, you'll film your day
starting thinking about the day in
the next two to three weeks, got it?
Got it, Boyd, you taking notes?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But make it a hustle day, load it up.
I want men, men, 15-35 being
inspired by how hard you went.
Got it?
- It'll probably have to be a shoot day.
- And then number three, I
really think you should put
out a song, one off summer
anthem in the next month
and we'll give it love.
I'm sure you're sitting on something.
I'm sure you've got a few contenders
and even if you have to like get somebody
to join in and give a hook or reverse it
and give it a little summer flavor.
And then four, most of all, and this
is why I really wanted to meet, I think
you guys already know
this, but we are here.
Bat phone, bat phone.
Three days before a show in
New York, nobody's going,
for some reason the
promoter fucked up, it's one
of those things, tell us how we can help.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, that's appreciated.
- Yes, for sure.
- No joke, we love you
more than most people.
- I love you, I'm convinced.
- Thank you.
- We must have the same taste.
I don't get that deep.
I'm thinking about the
seven people I've gone
all in for and you've got
like two or three of them.
(laughter)
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- It's a taste thing, it makes sense.
I really think you've got a shot.
I think you've got a place.
I think you need to be smart
about hacking cultures,
collaborations, the volume you put out,
the things you put out, how you do things,
but you can perform your ass off
and that is a real thing, that plays.
That's longevity to me.
So literally if you had one hit, for real,
like one true hit, like if
you were a one-hit wonder
who nobody wants to be
but it's better than being
a no-hit wonder, you're
so great at performing
that you would be coast-to-coast.
You'd be live the next
40 years of your life.
That gets me emotional
about you putting out
more music because then I
know it's just one song away.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm excited.
- How old are you?
- Twenty-two, just turned 22.
- (laughs) Love it.
Let's take a photo and I'm gonna bounce.
- Yeah.
- I know your platforms are on.
I knew that you would have those.
I know how you go.
Boyd, got the flash?
- One, two, three.
- Thank you so much.
- I've got love for you,
I've got love for you.
We'll continue to support.
- Yes, for sure.
- Hit me up on that thread.
Love you, I'll see you.
See you, Boyd.
- All right, I'll see you.